♪♪
-Shorter one today.
Only...
three pages.
Usually it's maybe five,
or sometimes six.
Not even three.
Like, two and a half,
two and a quarter?
It's going to be
a little bit shorter.
What, this is, like,
40% of a page,
2.4.
We had a joke about
Planet Fitness
which relied on their slogan
"This is a judgment-free zone."
The key we showed used
the UK spelling of "judgment."
A lot of you pointed that out.
Can I just say,
jackals pouncing on
the correct
spelling of "judgment,"
a little on the nose.
Uh, we said by next year,
Donald Trump is either
going to be president
or selling pictures of himself
in Times Square.
And then a bunch of
you said, 'Well, actually,
based on his current
civil trial,
he might be banned
from doing any business
at all in New York City,
which means he couldn't
sell photos of himself
in Times Square."
And then I guess my question is,
is that business?
Do you need a permit for that?
Does Elmo?
Does the guy
who dresses like Elmo
have a permit for that?
And if so, when he goes
to get the permit,
does he get it in his name,
or does he get it
in Elmo's name?
And when he walks in,
does he say, "I need a permit"
or does he say,
"Elmo need permit"?
You know what
the person who deals with
Times Square's permits isn't,
when Elmo walks in?
Tickled.
So it's shorter,
but we're making up for it.
I would say we've done
45% of the first page.
So if you're trying
to figure out how much
more it is,
I'd say we've done
not quite a fifth,
but again, it's going to be
on the shorter side.
"A Closer Look" yesterday
had a joke about Trump
putting googly eyes
on a bucket of KFC
and calling it his lawyer
in order to sneak it
into the courthouse,
because he hasn't been able
to eat in the courthouse.
Let me tell you
something about this --
big laugh.
Big laugh.
Then we said,
it worked
because it looks a lot like
his current lawyer.
Big laugh. Big laugh.
We're at two.
Going to hit rule of threes.
Third one plays the biggest.
Later we said, "This is what his
doctor looks like."
This ate [bleep].
This ate a whole bag of [bleep].
Then afterwards, Sal said,
"You know, we could fix it
and we could
put the googly eyes on it,
because clearly,
this required the googly eyes."
But we couldn't
in good faith
go back and fix it in post,
because that would be unfair
to the studio audience
who correctly judged it [bleep].
People at home would be like,
"Why didn't they
laugh at that one?"
We couldn't do that to them.
Also Graphics,
if you're ever on the fence
of whether or not
I want googly eyes, I want them.
Give me the googs.
Now, I don't want to belabor
this point,
because again,
today's a shorter one.
And by the way, don't --
Here's the thing with Graphics.
I got to make it clear,
because now I've been like,
"If it's ever on the fence."
Like, it's got to, you know --
For example,
if it's ever accompanying
the words "rest in peace,"
no googlies.
It wasn't a blanket statement.
We'll make it clear
in the future,
but this, guys.
Either the stethoscope
had to go on the bucket,
as if the bucket's a head
or, you know, put them
in Colonel Sanders' ears.
What's this?
Like...
No part of that's okay.
This is a personal attack.
So I went down to Graphics,
waving this around.
I mean,
I got it bigger when I...
when I wave it around,
it's like, a big ol'...
I come down, I'm like,
"Do you want to explain this?"
I was like,
"Do you have something
more important to focus on?"
And every one of them goes,
"Yeah, [bleep] 'Animal Flubs!'"
And I realize I've put
a lot of pressure on them.
I'd say we're 1.3 pages.
I received a thoughtful,
helpful note
that I'm going to take.
I show art sometimes
that is made by jackals,
and when I do that,
I should remember to say
the name of the person
who made the art.
I do appreciate the time
that goes into them,
even when I don't like
the actual art,
which is almost all the time.
So moving forward,
I'm going to do that.
I will say, there are some items
I had unboxed
after the new year,
and I have unfortunately
lost the names
of the person who did them.
So I do not know the name
of the person who did this.
I'm going to show you
this piece of art now.
Guys, one of my favorite
all-time football players,
the late, great Franco Harris,
one of the greatest,
if not the greatest play
in NFL history,
the Immaculate Reception.
I will sometimes just watch
the Immaculate Reception
on YouTube if I'm feeling down.
That's how much
I like watching that.
My least favorite thing
in the world
is the McDonald's Spokesmonster
Mac Tonight,
which makes this piece of art
here a real tweener for me.
That is the
"Mac Culate Reception."
Again, I forgot to write
down the name.
I'm trying to think of
what artist would even
do something like this...
Hitler?
I almost forgot.
I did this helpful thing
for you guys.
There we go.
There you go.
Oh, speaking of artists,
I said, uh...
"Andy Warhol paintings"
this week.
They're lithographs.
Want to see my favorite
Andy Warhol lithograph?
See? It works.
If I had asked, "Can you put
a stethoscope on it?"
It would have been like, here.
I'm going to skip this next one,
so then take that into account
as far as what
I said length was.
I said that 88, been informed
that 88 was a hate symbol
used by white supremacists,
and how angry that made me.
They don't get to just take
one of our numbers,
you know, that we use often.
Well, a jackal said
something I really liked,
And I think it would be
a helpful thing
to say to a white supremacist
if you ever saw them
sporting the ol' 88.
And this was
a very clean comment.
It was this and nothing else,
unadorned with setup
or postscript.
"88 is better than 69
because you get 8 twice."
I mean, I think if you said that
to a skinhead,
it would just stop them
in their tracks.
"What? What?"
"You heard me."
We're down to our last page.
Got big ol' fat,
square ice cubes.
A lot of people said
that I had bad Negroni cubes.
That was from Nate, who
sent in a new ice cube tray.
Thanks, Nate.
Nate went to a store.
He spent like $3
on an ice cube tray.
Remembered his name.
Life's not fair.
Why am I racing?
I referenced keto,
some sort of keto
junk science -- I'll say it --
pill online
that was using pictures.
I said it was using pictures
of Kelly Clarkson and I.
I should have said they were
using pictures
of me and Kelly Clarkson.
Kelly, did you know
I was saying it wrong?
-Yeah.
-You knew I was saying
it wrong
and you didn't say anything?
-Yeah.
-Well, then you can go.
No. No, where are you going?
No, you're going the wrong way.
Don't --
Don't go
towards the band, Kelly.
I mean, she has a TV --
I feel like she did that
on purpose.
It is how she walks, though.
She's always very --
I think they taught them that
on "American Idol."
Always let people
just see the front.
[ Clears throat ]
Oh, New Year's resolution.
We're right near the end.
Yeah.
Uh, New Year's resolution
was I'm going to
stop biting my nails.
So let's take a quick check in
and see how I'm doing.
-[ Screams ]
-Seven days.
Ah, well.
That's about it.
I don't regret the one
I didn't do.
In general, you know,
I just deal the cards I'm dealt.
That's how you say it.
That's the expression, right?
I realized why I stopped
getting invited to poker nights.
They'd deal me cards, and then
I would just deal them back.
You got to deal
the cards you're dealt.
No, man. You don't.
You got to play them.
Not what my daddy taught me.
Mm.
See me next week.